now gwyneth paltrow do you sound same
every year early on but I like the your
dad and what say during your life did
your dad sort of oh you know I was um it
was after I won I won an Oscar when I
was 26 so I was really young and I would
say it was about a year later you know I
think I mean my philosophy is like Fame
is actually not very good for us as
people because everybody starts removing
all of your obstacles and I think
friction is actually what makes you grow
and so all of a sudden I was this pretty
young woman and everybody was removing
my obstacles and I got to stop waiting
online etc whatever the case was and I
think incrementally I started just
behaving a little strangely or a little
weird and my father who Tom knew he sat
me down one day and he said in his
inimitable Brooklyn way you kind of
turning into an [ __ ] and it ended up
being this incredibly important moment
in my life where he really burst a
bubble for me where I could see oh this
is actually really dangerous that you
know everybody's wanting to remove
obstacles infantilizes you I think
that's one of the things that can you
can get away with ridiculous things
sometimes and Tom Holland obviously you
know this is all kind of new so that all
the Holland clan keeping your feet on
the ground yeah they do a good job - my
dad has is very annoying phrase um if I
ever do anything dickish you go got
you're such a movie star man
drives me up the wall but now I just go
yeah I think the [ __ ] conversation
may be happening
[Applause]
[Music]
you